الصين تدعو لاعاده التوحيد مع تايوان
سلميا تطالب باحترام ديمقراطيه شعبها
[موسيقى]
الاركان الاوكرانيه تؤكد صمود قواتها امام
القوات الروسيه الساعيه لمحاصره مدينه
بخموت
الاف الاسرائيليين يحتجون على خطط نتنياهو
لتغيير النظام القضائي والشرطه تعتقل
اربعه اشخاص
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير واهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه اهلا بكم مشاهدينا
هذه النشره مع هذا الخبر العاجل من
اوكرانيا بانه بانها تعلن حاله التاهب
الجوي في سبع مقاطعات تحسبا
لغارات روسيه قالت حكومه تايوان ان على
الصين احترام التزام الشعب التايوانيه
بالمفاهيم الاساسيه لسياده وديمقراطيه
والحريه واوضح بيان مجلس شؤون السياسه
الصينيه في تايوان ان على الصين معالجه
الامور عبر مضيق تايوان بطريقه عمليه
وعقلانيه ومتساويه ومحترمه للطرفين
جاء ذلك ردا على تصريحات رئيس وزراء الصين
لكي تشانغ الذي اكد سعيا بلاده لتعزيز
اعاده التوحيد السلمي مع تايواننا وطلب
باتخاذ خطوات حازمه لمعارضه استقلال
تايوان مشيرا الى تمسك بيكين بمبدا الصين
واحده الذي ينص على ان تايوان جزء من
الصين وترفض حكومه تايوان بشده مطالبات
بكين بالسياده وتقول ان السكان الجزيره
فقط من يمكنهم تقرير مستقبلهم
اعلنت الصين رفع ميزانيتها العسكريه بنسبه
7.2% لهذا العام في تسارع طفيف مقارنه
بالعام الماضي وجرى الاعلان عن هذا المعدل
وهو اعلى مما كان عليه عام 2022 في تقرير
لوزاره الماليه وتخطط بيكين لانفاق نحو
225 مليار دولار على دفاعها اي اقل بثلاث
مرات من ميزانيه
اعلن السفير الروسي لدى الصين ايغور
مورغولوف انا موسكو وابيكينت وعزيزان
التعاون العسكريه التقني ردا على محاولات
الناتو الذي يعمل على تعزيز قدراته في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ مورغولوف اشار
ايضا الى ان روسيا والصين ستواصلان شرح
المخاطر والتهديدات التي يمثلها وجود
الناتو في المنطقه لجميع دول اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ
وساتواصلان ايضا بناء التعاون العسكري مع
الدول الشركه للحفاظ على الهيكل الامنيه
للمنطقه
وحذر قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه يفريني
بريكوجين من ان اوكرانيا ستخرق اي اتفاق
مستقبلي سيتم التوصل اليه لوقف القتال
بدعم من النيتو واضاف بروجين انه يمكن
الوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار بمجرد انسحاب
اوكرانيا من الاقاليم الروسيه الجديده
ونزع سلاحها لكنه اكد ايضا ان القتال
سيعود مجددا بشكل اعنف بدعم من حلف الناتو
مشددا على ان روسيا ليس امامها سوى مواصله
حربها من اجل مستقبلها
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
قالت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه لا تزال
تحاول محاصره بخموت دون جدوى مضيفه ان
المدافعين عن المدينه صدو العديد من
الهجمات داخل المدينه وفم في محيطها وتحقق
قوات فاجنر تقدما في عمق مدينه باخموت
التي تشهد اعتى المعارك واعنفها بين الجيش
الاوكراني المتمسك بالمدينه والقوات
الروسيه التي تركت طريقا وحيدا لقوات كياف
من اجل الانسحاب تزامنا مع صراع بين
القاده الروس على كيفيه تسيير المعارك في
محاور العمليات العسك
ريه تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني بعد
تعزيزات موسكو العسكريه لمحور دانيت الذي
شهد تقدما للقوات الروسيه في ظل انتقادات
مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر القتاليه لمسار المعارك
التي تديرها الدفاع في محاور عديده ذلك
بعد ان حقق مقاتلوا فاغنر نجاحا ملموسا
شمال المقاطعه في مدينه
نحن نرسل مجموعه اخرى من المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين الى ديارهم والذين قاتلوا
بشجاعه ثم قتلوا وزير الدفاع الروسي
ظهر فجاه في ميدان معا
رك كرد منه على اتهامات بريجوجن الذي قال
ان الضباط الروس لا يعرفون شيئا عن مجرى
المعارك واوضاع الجنود مطالبا بتحميلهم
مسؤوليه الاخطاء
ننتظر منكم انجازات جديده وننتظر تحقيق
اهداف الخطط التي وضعناها لان جهدنا هام
جدا لوطننا
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الا ان تنافسا
كبيرا انطلق بين القاده الروس من اجل
تقديم انجازات ملموسه لسيد الكرمل انعكس
نقصد ذخيره والسلاح عند القوات الاوكرانيه
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه على مسار المعارك
في العمليه العسكريه ذلك ما ادى الى
انخفاض وتيره القصف الاوكراني على مناطق
الانفصاليين في دمباس لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاغبر دانياسك
وعقد وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه اجتماعا مع
قاده المجموعات القتاليه في مناطق العمليه
باوكرانيا وذكر بيان للوزاره ان شويغو
استمع الى تقارير من قاده
المجموعات حول الوضع القتالي والخطط
المستقبليه للعمليات واشار البيان الى ان
اكد استمرار الدعم العسكري والانتشار
العملياتي لتحقيق المهام المخططه من
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
افادت الحكومه الاوكرانيه بانها ستستخدم
الاصول الروسيه المصادره لاعاده بناء
البلاد وتعويض مواطنيها وقال رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني دينيس ميهال ان الاصول التي تمت
مصادرتها من البنوك الروسيه تزيد قيمتها
عن 460 مليون دولار وان الحكومه تعمل مع
الحلفاء لتطوير نظام قائم على معاهده
دوليه لتساعد في تحديد كيفيه اصدار
التعويضات للاوكرانيين
كشفت تقارير غربيه عن حاله من القلق
والفوضى في داخل الروسي عقب الهجمات
الاخيره على بعض المناطق الحدوديه التي
اصبحت مضطربه بشكل متزايد حيث تشهد عمليات
قصف متفرقه واعمال تخريبيه منذ انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه العام الماضي
تتزايد المخاوف في الداخل الروسي من تحول
البلاد الى ساحه اضافيه للحرب التي تدور
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه فالهجوم على منطقه
معارضون من الداخل ضد نظام بوتين يؤشر الى
تطور لافت خصوصا وانه ياتي بعد ايام من
هجمات بطائرات مسيره على مواقع داخل روسيا
تحطمت احداها قرب العاصمه موسكو استهداف
هذه المنطقه التي تخضع لتدابير امنيه
مكثفه كشف نقاط الضعف في الجيش الروسي
الذي بات امام موقف حرج يستدعي تغيير
خارطه المعارك واعلان الاحكام العرفيه في
المناطق الحدوديه بعد ان اثبت مقاتل
المعارض الدينس نيكيتن المنتمي لاقصى
اليمين الذي تبنى تنفيذ الهجوم قدرتهم على
اختراق بعض المناطق الحدوديه التي تخضع
لحراسه مشدده في العمق الروسي
وفق مقال نشرته صحيفه فايننشال تاينس فان
دينسا للانتفاضه ضد سياسه بوتين وتوعد
باستهداف المزيد من الدفاعات الروسيه وهو
ما خلف حاله من القلق والفوضى
اوكرانيا التي اظهرت عده مرات قدرتها على
الضرب بعمق خلف خطوط العدو بهجمات بطائرات
بدون طيار وعمليات تخريب جريئه نفت دعمها
المباشره للتنظيم وصفه للتهامات الروسيه
بالاستفزازيه بينما استغلت روسيا الحادثه
لتعزيز ادعائها بان الناتو يدير حربا
بالوكاله من خلال ارهابيين
وزعمت السلطات الروسيه ان الغاره اسفرت عن
مقتل مدنيين اثنين واصابه طفل
وفي اخبار مرتبطه بالملف الاوكراني والحرب
الدائره الدفاع البريطانيه اذا تتحدث بان
روسيا كثفت عملياتها بمجموعات المشاه بدعم
مدفعي اقل منذ نهايه فبراير وبانه روسيا
بشكل عام خفضت وتيره نيران هذه المدفعيه
بسبب نقص الذخيره يبدا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي استون جوله مرتقبه في الشرق
الاوسط تشمل الاردن ومصر واسرائيل بهدف
دعم وتقويه الشراكات وتعزيز التعاون وفق
موقع المونستر الامريكي وبحسب مسؤولينا في
البنتاجون سيحظى ملف التهديدات الايرانيه
والتنسيق الاقليمي لمواجهتها باهميه كبرى
خلال مباحثات كما سيبحث خلال جولته تصاعد
العنف بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وسبل
ضمان الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
ايران تتراجع وتسمح باستئناف التحقيق
بانشطتها النوويه وجراسي يؤكد اعادته
كاميرات المراقبه
اهلا بكم من جديد للاسبوع التاسع على
التوالي يحتاج الاسرائيليون ضد خطه تغيير
نظام القضاء التي تقوم به حكومه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وتظهر المقاطع
احتشهاد الالاف في الشوارع واغلاقها وفي
اخر انباء المظاهرات اعتقلت الشرطه اربعه
اشخاص في تل ابيب باعتبارهم ينتهكون
النظام العام
[موسيقى]
قال القائد الثاني لقوات الدعم السريع في
السودان عبد الرحيم دقلوا انه يجب تسليم
السلطه للشعب وانهم لن يسمحوا بقتل
المتظاهرين ما يؤكد خلافا بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش في وقت اكدت قوى الحريه
والتغيير موقفها من الاغتيال والقمع
المتواصل الذي ترى انه قد ينسف العمليه
السياسيه الجاريه الان في البلاد
سلم السلطه للشعب بدون لف ولا دوران
رسائل تتوالى من قاده الدعم السريع في
بريد السلطه العسكريه القائمه تؤكد ان
الخلافات لم تهدا او تحل هذه المره جاءت
التلميحات المبطنه من القائد الثاني لقوات
الدعم السريع عبد الرحيم والسبب هو قتل
المتظاهرين الرجل الذي يعتبر احد قاده
المنظومه الامنيه وجه انتقادا وكذلك
تهديدا بانهم لم يسمحوا باعتقال السياسيين
مره اخرى من الليله
وصاعدا بعد موت الشهيد ربنا يرحمه لن نسمح
باي قد الشباب المتظاهرين ولن نسمح باي
اعتقال للسياسيين
تحالف الحريه والتغيير والقوى الموقعه على
الاتفاق الاطري ينظرون بقلق ويستشعرون خطر
الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع لكن في ذات الوقت يبدو ان تصريحات
الدعم السريع هي الاقرب لموقفهم السياسي
ومع ذلك يظل السؤال الاهم والمطروح من
قبلهم عن جدول عمليه السياسيه الحاليه
الذي نراه الان هو تطور مهم نحن نرحب به
هنالك تحديات تواجه العمليه السياسيه من
ضمنها
الممارسات التي حدثت في الايام الماضيه ضد
المتظاهرين هذه تعوق العمليه السياسيه
وهذه تناقض روح الاتفاق الايطالي وبالتالي
هذه التحديات يعني تختبر صدق وجديه كل
الاطراف الموقعه لاتفاق الاطار على راسها
الجانب العسكري يرى العسكر والمدنيون ان
تسليم السلطه للشعب هو افضل الحلول لهذه
الازمه لكن كيف يتم ذلك مع تباين واضح
بينهما طالما هو نطق بكلمه بدون لف او
دوران انا اعتقد انها هي مفتاح الحل لكل
المشاكل هو تسليم السلطه للشعب بدون لف او
دوران بدون لف او دوران يعني تسليمها
بصوره فوريه بدلا من انتظار عمليه سياسيه
تلكات كثيرا وتاخرت كثيرا خلال الفتره
والشهور الماضيه ما انتهدا التصريحات
والرد عليها بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
حتى تعود مره اخرى لتفتح باب التساؤلات
على مصراعيه ما يجعل الوضع السياسي
السوداني على صفيح ساخن سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم
اعلن وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيدي
ان الاجهزه الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسمم
الطالبات في اكثر من 50 مدرسه وثانويه
بالبلاد ادت الى نقل عدد كبير منهن الى
المستشفى وقال وحيدي انه محققين عثروا على
عينات مشبوهه مشيرا الى ان هناك تحقيقات
متخصصه تستهدف الوقوف على اسباب ما سماها
المضاعفات التي حدثت للطالبات واضاف وزير
الداخليه ان صحه الطالبات تمثل الاولويه
القصوى لجميع المسؤولين خصوصا بعد اتساع
نطاق الاحتجاجات بهذا الشان في اكثر من
مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصففهان
موجه تسمم تجتاح مدارس الفتيات في ايران
تقارير اعلاميه ايرانيه افادت بتعرض
طالبات للتسمم في اكثر من 50 مدرسه وثنويه
بمزيج من غازات سامه وارسال عدد كبير منهن
الى المستشفيات
الطالبات تسممنا عن طريق الاستنشاق
ويعانين من اعراض الغثيان والضعف والدوار
والسعال وضيق التنفس
قناه ايران انترناشونال افادت باتساع نطاق
الاحتجاجات على تسمم الطالبات في اكثر من
مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان
وكرمانشاه واردبيل
حط طالبات تمثل الاولويه القصوى والاجهزه
الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسممين وقد عثرت على
عينه مشبوهه في عده مدارس بالبلاد هذا ما
اعلنه وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيدي
ثلاثه اشهر مرت على سلسله عمليات التسمم
التي تعرضنا لها الطالبات ولم يتم التعرف
على منفذي الهجمات قوات الامن الايراني
اعتقلت عددا من الاسر التي تجمعت امام
مبنى وزاره التربيه والتعليم قبل ترحيل
بعضهم الى سجن ايفين
ايرانيين اخر نفت منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه هي اتفاقا على تركيب كاميرات
جديده في المنشاه النوويه وقال المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الايرانيه انه لم يحدث اي
نقاش او اتفاق مع وفد مفتش الوكاله
الدوليه الذي زار ايران مؤخرا لتركيب هذه
الكاميرات وكان المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفيال جروس ياكد
بعد عودته من ايران انها وافقت على اعاده
تشغيل كاميرات مراقبه في عده مواقع نوويه
وزياده وتيره عمليات التف
اتفقنا على عدد من الاجراءات الملموسه
فخلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه كان هناك
انخفاض في بعض انشطه المراقبه لذا قررنا
مضاعفتها ووضع المزيد من الكاميرات وتعزيز
انظمه التدقيق عبر الانترنت واصلاح المعطل
منها المهم بالنسبه لنا هو ان ايران
ستلتزم بدرجه التخصيب المحدده لها في
منشاه فوردو وستحترم هذا الالتزام
وكشفت وكاله رويترز ان تقريرا لوكاله
الطاقه الذريه افاد بان ايران قدمت ضمانات
للقضايا العالقه بشان الملف النووي واضافت
رويترز نقلا عن التقرير نفسه انا طهران
تراجعت وسمحت الوكاله باستئناف التحقيق
بانشطتها كما ستعمل على توضيح تواجد
جزيئيات يورانيوم في منشاه فوردو
دعت كوريا الشماليه الامم المتحده الى حث
صول وواعنطن على الوقف الفوري للمناورات
العسكريه المشتركه بالاضافه الى
تصريحاتهما الاستفزازيه على حد وصف وزير
الخارجيه الكوري الشمالي كيمسون الذي
اعتبر ان التوتر بلغ مستوى خطير جدا بين
كوريا الشماليه وبين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه
خرج قطار عن القضبان في ولايه اوهايو
الامريكيه في ثاني حادث من نوعه يتعلق
بالسكك الحديديه في تلك الولايه خلال شهر
تقريبا وقالت السلطات المحليه ان المسعفين
في مكان الحادث عملوا على التاكد من عدم
وجود مواد السامه والحادث كما ذكرنا هو
الثاني بعد خروج قطار عن القضبان في
الثالث من فبراير الماضي بولايه اوهايو
مما ادى الى انبعاث مواد كيميائيه سامه في
البيئه واجبار الالاف على الاخلاء
وزوجته قد يفقدان مكانا خاصا لهما في حال
عودتهما للمملكه المتحده هذا بسبب قرار
الملك تشارلز بطردهما من منزله مارفي في
الذي عرضه الملك تشارلز على اخيه الامير
اندرو للسكنى
الامير هاري وزوجته ميجا ميركل سيطردان من
منزلهما الريفي
رغم انفاقهما الملايين على ترميمه فهل
سيستردان بعض هذه الاموال الخبراء يقولون
في احلامهما
او منزل الريفي يقع على اراضي قلعه وينسور
غربيه لندن وكان من المفترض ان يكون مقر
اقامه هاري وميجان الرسمي في بريطانيا قبل
ان يتخلى بهما الملكي
المقر المكون من 10 غرف نوم كان هديه
الملك الراحله اليزابيث
بعد حفل زفافهما عام 2018
لينتقل اليه الزوجان لفتره محدوده عقب
ولاده طفلهما الاول
وسرعان ما ذهب للعيش في ولايه كاليفورنيا
بعد تحررهما من قيود الملكيه في عام 2020
املا في بناء حياه ومهن جديده
هاري وميجن وادعى العرش ومعه فروج
موركوتيج وكذلك ملايين الدولارات لم
يستخدم الزوجان مقر اقامتهما في خلال
مكوثهما في امريكا الا في مناسبات قليله
ورغم انهما انفقا ثلاثه ملايين
الف دولار على تجديد وترميمه الا انهما
معرضان للطرد وعدم استرداد تلك المبالغ
يبدو ان هذا سيكون ثمنا باهضا مقابل
اصرارهما على حياه طبيعيه
جرد الملك تشارلز الثالث ابنه الامير هاري
وزوجته
في الحادي عشر من يناير بعد يوم من نشر
هاري مذكراته المثيره للجدل
التي انتقد خلالها افراد العائله الملكيه
في هذا النشره تذكير بالعناوين
الصين تدعو لاعاده التوحيد مع تايوان
سلميا تطالب باحترام ديمقراطيه شعبها
[موسيقى]
الاركان الاوكرانيه تؤكد صمود قواتها امام
القوات الروسيه الساعيه لمحاصره مدينه
بخموت
الاف الاسرائيليين يحتاجون ضد خطط نتنياهو
لتغيير النظام القضائي والشرطه تعتقل
اربعه اشخاص
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]